أهلاً بكم مجدداً في فهم المعلومات والحوسبة الكمية اسمي John Watrous وأنا المدير
التقني للتعليم في IBM Quantum هذا هو الدرس الثامن من السلسلة وهو الدرس الأخير في
الوحدة الثانية من السلسلة التي تتناول الخوارزميات الكمية تحدثنا عن نموذج الاستعلام للحوسبة بما في ذلك الخوارزميات الكمية
التي تقدم مزايا مُثبتة على الخوارزميات الكلاسيكية ضمن هذا النموذج ناقشنا المفاهيم الأساسية المرتبطة
بالخوارزميات الكمية وكيف يمكننا قياس التكلفة الحسابية وفي الدرس السابق ناقشنا تقدير الطور وخوارزمية Shor
في هذا الدرس سنناقش خوارزمية Grover التي توفر ميزة تربيعية للحوسبة الكمية على
الخوارزميات الكلاسيكية لما يُسمى مسائل البحث غير المنظم والتي سأشرحها عندما ندخل في
الدرس هذه كلها مواضيع أساسية تتعلق بالخوارزميات الكمية وهناك خوارزميات كمية
أخرى بالإضافة إلى نماذج عامة توحّد بين خوارزميات كمية مختلفة وتقنيات خوارزمية كمية و
إذا كنت مهتماً أشجعك على الاطلاع على حديقة الخوارزميات الكمية التي تصنّف الخوارزميات الكمية المعروفة وتتضمن العديد من المراجع
لأوراق البحث الأصلية التي ساهمت في تطويرها لكن بالنسبة لهذه السلسلة
سنلتزم بالأساسيات فقط وبدءاً من الدرس القادم سننتقل إلى موضوع جديد لكن
أولاً لنتحدث عن خوارزمية Grover إليكم نظرة عامة على الدرس سنبدأ بمناقشة قصيرة حول
المسألة الحسابية التي سنتناولها وهي البحث غير المنظم بشكل بديهي يمكنك
التفكير في مسألة البحث غير المنظم كالبحث في مجموعة من العناصر غير مرتبة ولم يتم تنظيمها بطريقة مفيدة
ثم سنناقش خوارزمية Grover وهي خوارزمية كمية تقدم ميزة تربيعية على
الخوارزميات الكلاسيكية وسنوضح بدقة ما يعنيه ذلك قريباً وصف عالي المستوى جداً لـ
كيفية عمل هذه الخوارزمية هو أنه أولاً هناك خطوة تهيئة ثم عملية سأشير إليها بـ
عملية Grover تُكرَّر عدداً من المرات ثم أخيراً يتم إجراء قياس يكشف عن مرشح
حل لمسألة البحث سأشرح ما هي عملية Grover وكيف يمكن
تنفيذها على حاسوب كمي ثم سنقوم بتحليل هذه العملية لفهم أفضل لما تفعله ولماذا هي مفيدة في
البحث الجزء الثالث من الدرس يتعلق بعدد التكرارات
في خوارزمية Grover أو بعبارة أخرى عدد المرات التي يجب فيها تطبيق عملية Grover بافتراض أننا نريد
تعظيم احتمال نجاح الخوارزمية في إيجاد ما نبحث عنه مع تقليل تكلفتها
في نفس الوقت سنبدأ بمسألة البحث الفريد وهي حالة خاصة يوجد فيها حل واحد بالضبط لمسألة
البحث ثم سننظر فيما يحدث عندما تكون هناك حلول متعددة وأخيراً سأختم
الدرس ببعض الملاحظات المختصرة حول خوارزمية Grover وتعميماتها لنبدأ بـ
المسألة الحسابية التي سنتناولها طوال الدرس أولاً كما نفعل غالباً سنجعل
سيجما تمثل الأبجدية الثنائية وسنستخدم هذا الترميز طوال الدرس لذا لن أستمر في
تذكيركم افترضوا أن لدينا دالة f تأخذ سلاسل ثنائية بطول معين n وتعطي
الأبجدية الثنائية افتراضنا هو أنه يمكننا تقييم هذه الدالة بسهولة على سبيل
المثال ربما لدينا circuit بولياني لهذه الدالة حجمه متعدد حدود في N هذا لا يعني أن هذه
دالة بسيطة بأي شكل أو أن لدينا فهماً جيداً بشكل خاص لهذه الدالة مثلاً ربما لدينا
circuit بولياني معقد وفوضوي لحساب F يسمح لنا بتقييمها على سلاسل إدخال مختلفة لكنه ليس بالضرورة ذا
شكل أنيق مصمم لتسهيل حياتنا هدفنا هو إيجاد حل وهو
سلسلة ثنائية بطول n تجعل F تُقيَّم إلى واحد بشكل عام هذه مسألة حسابية صعبة جداً
أو على الأقل نشك أنها صعبة جداً وبشكل خاص إذا كان المدخل هو في الواقع
وصف circuit بولياني لحساب الدالة f فهذه مسألة NP-complete طريقة
لصياغة هذه المسألة هي كمسألة استعلام وبالفعل لأغراض هذا الدرس من المعقول
التفكير في هذه المسألة بشكل كامل في سياق نموذج الاستعلام لكن عندما نفكر أين أو متى قد تظهر هذه
المسألة عملياً فمن الأكثر طبيعية التفكير في f كأنها تُحسب بواسطة circuit
بولياني كما رأينا في الدرس السادس يمكننا ربط وجهتي النظر هاتين من خلال البناء الذي مررنا به لأخذ circuit بولياني و
تحويله إلى circuit كمي لتنفيذ عملية استعلام أو gate استعلام في كل الأحوال من الناحية المفاهيمية
المدخل للمسألة هو هذه الدالة f ونحن نبحث عن حل إن وُجد وإن لم
يكن هناك حل بمعنى أن F تبين أنها دالة الصفر الثابتة فالمخرج الصحيح هو الإبلاغ
بأنه لا توجد حلول هذه مسألة بحث غير منظم بمعنى أنه ليس هناك
شيء مميز في F يجعل إيجاد حل سهلاً ليس الأمر كأننا نبحث
في بيانات تم ترتيبها مسبقاً أو تم تحميلها في بنية بيانات تسهّل البحث وليس هناك وعد على
الدالة f قد يساعدنا طريقة للتفكير في الأمر هي أنه مثل البحث عن رقم هاتف
معين في دليل الهاتف مقابل البحث عن اسم وهو أسهل بكثير بافتراض أن الأسماء قد
تم ترتيبها أبجدياً من الناحية العملية لا يتعلق الأمر فعلاً بالبحث في البيانات
التي نميل إلى تنظيمها وتخزينها بطريقة تسهّل البحث بل هو أكثر تمثيلاً للبحث عن
حل لمعادلة معقدة مثلاً أو ربما البحث عن التركيبة التي تفتح
قفلاً كملاحظة جانبية من المنطقي التفكير في هذه المسألة في سياق نموذج الاستعلام بغض النظر عن شعورنا
تجاه الصلة العملية لهذا النموذج بالطبع لا توجد أوراكل أو صناديق سوداء في الحياة الواقعية لكن حتى
نعرف خلاف ذلك الـ circuits البوليانية المعقدة والغامضة تشبه نوعاً ما الصناديق
السوداء الآن لنفكر في خوارزميات لحل مسألة البحث غير المنظم هذه وسنقوم بذلك
في نموذج الاستعلام فقط من أجل البساطة إذا كان لدينا circuit بولياني لدالتنا بدلاً من صندوق أسود
فلا يزال بإمكاننا تشغيل خوارزميات الاستعلام عليه لكن بالطبع لا يمكننا استبعاد احتمال اكتشاف خوارزمية جديدة
لهذه المسألة لا تعتمد على إجراء استعلامات لكننا لن نشغل أنفسنا بهذا
الاحتمال أولاً بعض الترميزات العدد الإجمالي لسلاسل الإدخال للدالة f هو 2 أس
n الصغير حيث n الصغير هو طول سلاسل الإدخال لـ F ومن الآن فصاعداً سأجعل N الكبير يساوي هذا الرقم 2 أس
n الصغير من الشائع جداً أن يستخدم الناس حرفاً كبيراً هكذا للدلالة على اثنين أس النسخة الصغيرة
من ذلك الحرف سنتحدث كثيراً عن الرقم N الكبير لذا هذا سيكون
مناسباً وسيساعد في إبقاء الأمور أكثر ترتيباً ومرة أخرى هذا الترميز ساري المفعول
طوال الدرس بالطبع يمكننا حل مسألة البحث كلاسيكياً ببساطة عن طريق
المرور على جميع سلاسل n بت الممكنة بأي ترتيب نختاره وتقييم F على كل واحدة
منها إذا وجدنا حلاً في أي لحظة يمكننا التوقف لكن في أسوأ الحالات سننتهي بتقييم F على كل
سلسلة إدخال لذا هذا يتطلب N أي N الكبير
استعلاماً يمكننا اختيار قياس تكلفة هذه العملية الحسابية بطريقة مختلفة ليس فقط بعدد الاستعلامات لكن عدد الاستعلامات
يمثل عدد المرات التي يتعين علينا تقييم الدالة f ومن المعقول توقع أن تقييمات f ستهيمن على تكلفة
هذه العملية الحسابية هذا في الواقع أفضل ما يمكننا فعله بخوارزمية حتمية
ومرة أخرى هذا في سياق نموذج الاستعلام إذا استعلمنا عن كل سلسلة
إدخال باستثناء واحدة وكانت F تأخذ القيمة صفر على جميعها حتى الآن كيف يمكننا التأكد أن السلسلة الأخيرة
ليست حلاً والإجابة هي أننا لا نستطيع لذا نحتاج فعلاً إلى كل الـ N استعلام في أسوأ
الحالات يمكننا أيضاً استخدام العشوائية وهذا يمكن أن يقدم بعض التحسينات الطفيفة جداً مثل تقليل
العدد المتوقع من الاستعلامات اللازمة لإيجاد حل عندما يكون موجوداً أو يمكننا فعلياً مقايضة احتمال
الصحة بتخفيض في الاستعلامات لكن مهما نظرت إليها سنحتاج إلى عدد استعلامات خطي
في N فكلاسيكياً نحتاج إلى عدد خطي من الاستعلامات أي خطي
في N الكبير خوارزمية Grover هي خوارزمية كمية للبحث تعمل بشكل أفضل فهي تتطلب فقط O كبير من
الجذر التربيعي لـ N استعلاماً هذه الاستعلامات تحدث في تراكب لذا ليس سحراً لكنه
تحسن كبير على ما هو ممكن كلاسيكياً وهذا ما يُقصد بالميزة التربيعية
هل يمكن تحويل هذه الميزة التربيعية للكمي على الكلاسيكي إلى ميزة فعلية بالمعنى العملي
على الأرجح لا في أي وقت قريب لكن في المستقبل البعيد من يدري لكن حتى لو
لم تؤدِ خوارزمية Grover أبداً إلى ميزة عملية للبحث فهي مع ذلك جزء مهم من
أساس الخوارزميات الكمية وتستحق الفهم قبل أن ننتقل إلى خوارزمية Grover نفسها نحتاج أن
نتحدث بإيجاز عن ما يُسمى بـ gates استعلام الطور كثير من الخوارزميات الكمية في نموذج الاستعلام يتم التعبير عنها بشكل طبيعي
باستخدام gates استعلام الطور وسنرى أن خوارزمية Grover هي مثال
محدد لنبدأ بنظرة سريعة على gates الاستعلام العادية لدالة f من
الشكل الذي تحدثنا عنه gate الاستعلام UF يُعرَّف على حالات الأساس القياسي كما هو موضح على
الشاشة وللتراكبات من حالات الأساس القياسي يتحدد الفعل بالخطية ومن الجدير بالتذكير
أنه من circuit بولياني لـ f يمكننا فعلاً بناء circuit لهذه العملية UF بتكلفة
خطية في حجم الـ circuit البولياني أما gate استعلام الطور لـ f من ناحية أخرى والذي سنرمز له بـ
الاسم ZF فيعمل هكذا وبالتحديد هذا الـ gate يعمل على
n صغير qubit مقابل n صغير زائد واحد qubit وهو ببساطة يُدخل قيمة الدالة تلقائياً
في الطور بدلاً من عمل XOR لقيمة المخرج على qubit إضافي كما لدينا في
UF فإذا فكرنا فيما يحدث عندما نستخدم ارتداد الطور على gate UF
فنحن ببساطة ننفذ gate ZF نحتاج إلى حالة ناقص وتكلّف تقييماً واحداً
لـ UF لكننا فعلاً نسترجع حالة الناقص ويمكننا استخدامها للتالي إذا أردنا أو يمكننا
ببساطة التخلص منها هذا ما هو gate استعلام الطور الآن إذا كان لدينا فقط
gate استعلام طور ZF وهذه هي الطريقة الوحيدة للوصول إلى الدالة f فلا يمكننا فعلياً
استرجاع gate UF لكن إذا كان لدينا نسخة مُتحكَّم بها من ZF فيمكننا
بناء gate UF وسأترك ذلك لكم كـ
تمرين بالإضافة إلى gate استعلام الطور للدالة f سنحتاج أيضاً إلى gate استعلام طور لدالة OR على n بت
أو بعبارة أخرى الدالة التي تأخذ القيمة صفر عندما تُعطى سلسلة الأصفار وفيما عدا ذلك
تأخذ القيمة واحد وبشكل صريح طريقة عمل Zor على حالات الأساس القياسي موضحة
هنا على الشاشة هذا الـ gate ليس له أي اعتماد على الدالة f لذا لا يتطلب
أي استعلامات وطريقة لبناء circuit كمي ينفّذ هذه العملية هي القيام بشيء
مشابه لما فعلناه للدالة f إلا أننا نبدأ بـ circuit بولياني يحسب دالة OR على
n بت والآن بعد أن حصلنا على هذه الـ gates نحن مستعدون للانتقال إلى القسم
التالي الآن سنناقش خوارزمية Grover بدءاً من وصف الخوارزمية نبدأ بتهيئة
n صغير qubit كل منها في حالة زائد أو بعبارة أخرى نضع هذه الـ qubits في تراكب متساوٍ لجميع
السلاسل الثنائية بطول n ما سنفعله هو توجيه حالة هذه الـ qubits فعلياً
نحو حل لذا من البديهي أن نبدأ في هذه الحالة لأننا لا نعرف شيئاً عن الدالة f بعد
في هذه المرحلة كل سلسلة لها نفس الاحتمال أن تكون حلاً وهذا ينعكس في أن هذه الـ qubits في تراكب متساوٍ لجميع
السلاسل ثم نكرر نطبق عملية Grover بشكل متكرر وهي فعلاً قلب
الخوارزمية وسأصفها بعد لحظة نطبق هذه العملية T مرات حيث T عدد صحيح غير
سالب لكن هذا العدد لا تحدده الخوارزمية نفسها فعلياً علينا اختيار T بطريقة ما وفي القسم
التالي سنتحدث عن اختيارات جيدة لـ T لكن الآن يمكننا التفكير في عدد التكرارات T على
أنه عشوائي وأخيراً نقيس في الأساس القياسي وهذا يعطينا
حلاً مرشحاً ليس هناك ضمان أنه حل لكن إذا اخترنا T بشكل جيد فإن
احتمال الحصول على حل يمكن جعله كبيراً وها هي عملية Grover
نفسها التي سميناها G هي تركيب من العمليات كلها على N qubit لذا هذه عملية على N
qubit أولاً لدينا gate ZF أو بعبارة أخرى gate استعلام طور لـ
دالة الإدخال f يليه طبقة من gates Hadamard ثم لدينا Zor وهو gate استعلام الطور لدالة OR
وأخيراً طبقة أخرى من gates Hadamard نرى إذن أن تكراراً واحداً في
الخطوة الثانية يمكن تنفيذه بواسطة circuit بالشكل الموضح هنا على الشاشة وهنا لدينا أربعة qubits بالمناسبة
لكن بشكل عام يمكن أن يكون لدينا أي عدد من الـ qubits نقطة أساسية يجب ملاحظتها هنا أننا نحتاج استعلاماً واحداً لـ f لتنفيذ G
نحتاج استعلاماً واحداً لتنفيذ ZF ولا يعتمد أي من العمليات الأخرى على F لذا لا تتطلب أي استعلامات إذن هذا الرقم T الذي
يمثل عدد مرات تطبيق G في الخطوة الثانية يمثل أيضاً عدد الاستعلامات التي
نحتاجها هذه طريقة نموذجية لاستخدام خوارزمية Grover لكنها بالتأكيد ليست الطريقة الوحيدة كما قلت
سابقاً أول شيء يجب فعله هو اختيار T وسندخل في ذلك في القسم التالي
لأي T نختاره نشغّل خوارزمية Grover لـ T تكرار ونحصل على حل مرشح
X ليس هناك ضمان أن X حل فعلاً لكن يمكننا إنفاق استعلام إضافي واحد للتحقق إذا كان لدينا حل يمكننا
إخراج ذلك الحل والتوقف وإلا يمكننا إما المحاولة مرة أخرى ربما باختيار مختلف لـ T
وليس بالضرورة أو يمكننا الاستسلام والإبلاغ بأنه لا توجد حلول كما قلت سابقاً هذه
ليست الطريقة الوحيدة لاستخدام الخوارزمية لكنها طريقة طبيعية لتطبيقها على مسألة البحث بعد ذلك سنرى ما تفعله عملية Grover
فعلاً بحالة الـ N qubits التي تعمل عليها لنفكر في الـ N qubits كأنها تشكل
سجلاً واحداً سأسميه Q فقط لاختيار اسم تذكروا أن ما نفعله أولاً في
خوارزمية Grover هو وضع Q في تراكب منتظم لجميع سلاسل n بت ونفعل ذلك بتطبيق gates Hadamard
على n qubit في حالة الأصفار ثم نكرر عملية Grover G ثم
نقيس سيكون مفيداً تقسيم مجموعة جميع سلاسل n بت إلى مجموعتين A0 و
A1 حيث A0 تحتوي على جميع السلاسل التي تجعل F تُقيَّم إلى صفر و A1 تحتوي على جميع السلاسل التي تجعل F
تُقيَّم إلى واحد بطريقة أخرى A1 تحتوي على جميع الحلول لمسألة
البحث بينما A0 تحتوي على جميع اللاحلول سنكون مهتمين بشكل خاص
بحالتين كميتين واحدة هي التراكب المنتظم على جميع اللاحلول وهي ket A0 و
الأخرى منتظمة على جميع الحلول وهي ket A1 يجب أن أشير إلى أن هذه التعريفات تكون منطقية فقط
عندما تكون هذه المجموعات غير فارغة لأنه بخلاف ذلك نجمع صفر أشياء ونقسم على صفر وبينما نمضي
في هذا التحليل لخوارزمية Grover سنفترض ذلك يمكننا بسهولة جداً معرفة ما
تفعله خوارزمية Grover عندما تكون f إما دالة الصفر الثابتة أو دالة الواحد الثابتة بمعاملتهما كحالات خاصة لكنني سأترك ذلك
لكم لتفعلوه بأنفسكم ليس مفاجئاً أنه إذا كانت كل سلسلة حلاً فسنحصل فعلاً على
حل عندما نقيس وإذا لم تكن هناك حلول فلن نحصل على واحد لأنه في تلك الحالة لا يوجد
أي منها لكن من أجل هذا التحليل سنفترض أن كلتا المجموعتين غير فارغتين حتى تكون
تعريفات هاتين الحالتين منطقية بالمناسبة هذا ترميز شائع جداً
عندما يكون لدينا مجموعة منتهية غير فارغة S يمكننا كتابة ket S لتعني التراكب المنتظم على
عناصر تلك المجموعة تماماً كما لدينا هنا فلنجمع هذه التعريفات هكذا وسنرى كيف ترتبط
بخوارزمية Grover الخطوة الأولى في خوارزمية Grover هي خطوة التهيئة التي تضع Q في تراكب منتظم
على جميع سلاسل n بت ولإعطاء هذه الحالة اسماً يسهل التعرف عليه سأسميها
ket U حيث U اختصار لمنتظم من المهم لغرض التحليل أن نلاحظ أولاً أن
هذه الحالة المنتظمة ket U موجودة في الفضاء الجزئي المولَّد بالمتجهين ket A0 و ket
A1 وبالتحديد إذا أخذنا التركيب الخطي لهاتين الحالتين الموضح هنا على الشاشة سنحصل على ket
U الآن المفتاح لكامل التحليل هو حقيقة أن حالة Q تبقى في
هذا الفضاء الجزئي ثنائي الأبعاد بغض النظر عن عدد مرات تطبيق عملية Grover لذا كل شيء سيتلخص
فيما يحدث في فضاء جزئي ثنائي الأبعاد الآن لنرَ ما تفعله عملية Grover وبالتحديد ما
تفعله بالمتجهات في الفضاء الجزئي ثنائي الأبعاد المولَّد بـ ket A0 و ket
A1 من المفيد تخيل أن G مقسمة إلى جزأين أحدهما gate ZF
والآخر gate Zor محصور بين طبقتين من gates Hadamard
هذا هو تعريف ZF من قبل ومن السهل جداً من ذلك التعريف أن نرى أن
فعله على حالتينا التراكبان المنتظمان للاحلول والحلول هو ببساطة وضع إشارة سالب
أمام ket A1 بينما لا يحدث شيء لـ ket A0 وهذا كل ما نحتاج معرفته حقاً
عن ZF لغرض هذا التحليل بالنسبة للجزء الثاني وهو
gate Zor محصور بين طبقتين من gates Hadamard لنبدأ بتذكر كيف يُعرَّف Zor طريقة لكتابته
هي كما هو موضح على الشاشة هذا نفس التعبير كما من قبل وطريقة أخرى للتعبير عنه باستخدام ترميز
Dirac هي هكذا ويمكنك التحقق من هذا التعبير فقط بالتفكير في كيفية عمل العملية على
الطرف الأيمن على حالات الأساس القياسي وبالتحديد لا تفعل شيئاً لحالة الأصفار وكل
حالة أساس قياسي أخرى تحصل على إشارة سالب وهو ما يتوافق مع تعريف Z
or فإذا حصرنا هذه العملية بين طبقتين من gates Hadamard نحصل على تعبير مشابه إلا
أنه بدلاً من حالة الأساس القياسي للأصفار لدينا الآن التراكب المنتظم ket U وذلك لأن H tensor
n يحول حالة الأساس القياسي للأصفار إلى ket U وأيضاً H tensor n هو المرافق المنقول لنفسه فيعمل بطريقة مماثلة
من اليمين على bra بدلاً من ket والآن سنكتشف
ما تفعله G بمتجهينا A0 و A1 باستخدام الحقائق التي لاحظناها للتو
لنبدأ بـ A0 أولاً لنعوّض التعبير
الذي حصلنا عليه لـ gate Zor المحصور بين طبقتين من gates Hadamard بعد ذلك يمكننا استخدام حقيقة أن ZF لا يفعل شيئاً
لـ ket A0 فيمكننا حذف عملية ZF والآن باستخدام الوصف
لـ ket U الذي لدينا هنا مع حقيقة أن ket A0 و ket A1 متجهان متعامدان وحدويان يمكننا حساب
جداء هذا bra هنا مع هذا ket وما نحصل عليه هو الجذر التربيعي لعدد اللاحلول
مقسوماً على N يمكننا استخدام هذه الحقيقة لتقييم ما نحصل عليه وبالتعويض بتعبيرنا لـ ket U و
التبسيط نحصل على النتيجة النهائية الموضحة هنا على الشاشة وبالتحديد لاحظوا أن هذا
المتجه موجود في الفضاء الجزئي ثنائي الأبعاد المولَّد بـ ket A0 و ket A1 كما اقترحت سابقاً و
كذلك المعاملات هي أعداد حقيقية كما هو الحال دائماً تحققوا من ذلك بوتيرتكم
الخاصة إذا اخترتم ذلك أميل إلى المرور على هذه الأمور بسرعة في هذه الفيديوهات مع
توقع أنكم ستوقفون الفيديو لتفكروا فيها إذا اخترتم ذلك فلننظّف هذا حتى
نتمكن من حفظ النتيجة النهائية لاحقاً والآن سنفعل شيئاً مشابهاً للمتجه ket
A1 يمكننا استخدام نفس تعبير G كما من قبل وهذه المرة gate ZF يُدخل
إشارة سالب وهو ما ينعكس هنا بأننا بدّلنا الحدين في العملية بين
الأقواس ثم نتابع بطريقة مشابهة جداً والنتيجة النهائية مشابهة إلا أن المعاملين
مُبدَّلان ولدينا الآن إشارة سالب أمام أحدهما وهذا ما يعطيه الجبر ومرة أخرى يمكنكم
التحقق من ذلك بوتيرتكم الخاصة لاحظوا أننا مرة أخرى حصلنا على تركيب خطي حقيقي لمتجهينا ket A0 و
ket A1 سننظف هذا أيضاً ونضع النتيجة النهائية مع الأخرى والآن يمكننا أن نرى كيف تعمل G
على الفضاء الجزئي المولَّد بمتجهينا طريقة لفعل ذلك هي التعبير عنها بمصفوفة 2×2 وهي M الموضحة
هنا على الشاشة ولكي نكون واضحين ما نفعله هنا هو أننا نربط الصف الأول والعمود الأول
بـ ket A0 والصف الثاني والعمود الثاني بـ ket A1 حتى الآن في السلسلة
استخدمنا المصفوفات فقط لوصف طريقة عمل العمليات على حالات الأساس القياسي لكن من الشائع استخدام المصفوفات
لوصف أفعال التطبيقات الخطية على مجموعات مختلفة من المتجهات ليس فقط حالات الأساس القياسي وهنا نتحدث عما تفعله العملية G
بالمتجهين ket A0 و ket A1 يمكننا قول المزيد عما تفعله G بالمتجهات في
فضاء ket A0 و ket A1 المولَّد إذا نظرنا عن كثب لهذه المصفوفة M وبالتحديد ما سنجده هو
أن M هي مصفوفة دوران بمعنى أن فعلها على هذا الفضاء ثنائي الأبعاد يمكن وصفه كدوران بزاوية
ثابتة معينة هناك طريقتان مختلفتان لرؤية ذلك وإحداهما هي ملاحظة
أن هذه المصفوفة M يمكن التعبير عنها كمربع مصفوفة تبدو أبسط إلى حد ما قد يكون من الصعب ملاحظة ذلك إذا
كنا ننظر إلى M بمفردها لكن هذا ليس شيئاً نحتاج لاكتشافه بأنفسنا نحتاج فقط للتحقق منه ويمكننا ذلك ببساطة عن طريق
تربيع المصفوفة على اليمين طريقة أخرى لكتابة المصفوفة على اليمين بدون التربيع هي
موضحة على الشاشة وهذه هي الطريقة المعتادة لوصف دوران بزاوية معينة ثيتا على شكل
مصفوفة الزاوية المحددة التي ندور بها هي عكس الجيب للجذر التربيعي لعدد
الحلول مقسوماً على N وبالمناسبة لأن هذه أول مرة نراها دعوني أشير إلى أن
هذه الزاوية مهمة جداً ستستمر في الظهور بينما نتابع هذا
التحليل وسيطة عكس الجيب هي عدد بين 0 و 1 وتحديداً الطريقة التي
نفسر بها عكس الجيب هنا هي أنها الزاوية بين 0 و π/2 التي تعطينا الوسيطة عندما نأخذ
الجيب هذه إذن طريقة للتفكير في هذه المصفوفة التي ربّعناها لنحصل على
M ولأن تربيع المصفوفة هو نفس تطبيقها مرتين نرى أن M يمكن كتابتها بديلاً كـ
دوران ليس بزاوية ثيتا بل بـ 2 ضرب ثيتا لأنه بالتربيع ندور بزاوية ثيتا
مرتين طريقة مختلفة للتحقق من كل هذا بالمناسبة في حال كان ذلك مفيداً هي البدء بهذا التعبير النهائي لـ M
واستخدام صيغ الزاوية المزدوجة من حساب المثلثات للحصول على التعبير الأصلي لـ
M وهذا هو تعبير M الذي يصف الفعل الذي تقوم به G على الفضاء الجزئي المولَّد بـ ket A0 و ket A1 الذي
سيكون أكثر فائدة للمضي قدماً والآن بالعودة إلى خوارزمية Grover نفسها بعد
خطوة التهيئة وقبل أن نجري أي تطبيقات لـ G حالة سجل الـ N qubit لدينا Q هي ket U
التراكب المنتظم على جميع سلاسل n بت وهنا لدينا نفس تعبير ket U بدلالة ket A0 و
ket A1 كما من قبل لكن الآن بعد أن حددنا هذه الزاوية ثيتا نرى أنه يمكننا
بديلاً كتابة ket U كـ جيب تمام ثيتا ضرب ket A0 زائد جيب ثيتا ضرب ket
A1 هذا واضح لمعامل ket A1 وللمعامل الآخر نحتاج فقط لملاحظة أن حجم A0 زائد
حجم A1 يساوي N ثم نحصل عليه من بعض حساب المثلثات الأساسي إذن هذه هي الحالة التي
نبدأ بها وأول مرة نطبق G ندور بزاوية 2 ضرب ثيتا فتصبح الزاوية الإجمالية 3 ضرب
ثيتا وإذا طبقنا G مرة أخرى تزداد الزاوية إلى 5 ثيتا لأننا فعلياً دُرنا بزاوية
إضافية مقدارها 2 ثيتا وهكذا فبعد T تطبيق لـ G يمكننا تمثيل
الحالة التي نحصل عليها كما هو موضح على الشاشة حيث زاوية حالتنا تساوي (2T+1) ضرب ثيتا أي 2 ضرب ثيتا
لكل تطبيق لـ G بالإضافة إلى ثيتا إضافية لأن ذلك هو الحالة التي بدأنا بها
يمكننا أيضاً التفكير في فعل عملية Grover بمصطلحات هندسية وهذا يساعد في إلقاء بعض الضوء على كيفية
عملها ولماذا تأثيرها هو تدوير حالة السجل Q إليكم الفكرة الرئيسية عملية Grover
هي تركيب من الجزأين اللذين حددناهما بالفعل أحدهما ZF والآخر Zor محصور بين
طبقتين من gates Hadamard هذان الجزءان هما
انعكاسات وعندما نركّب انعكاسين نحصل على دوران فلنرَ كيف يعمل هذا بمزيد من
التفصيل أولاً لنركز على ZF وسنقصر اهتمامنا على
نفس الفضاء الجزئي ثنائي الأبعاد الذي تحدثنا عنه أي المولَّد بـ ket A0 و ket
A1 كما لاحظنا بالفعل فعل ZF على هذا الفضاء بسيط جداً لا يفعل
شيئاً لـ ket A0 ويضع إشارة سالب أمام ket A1 هذا انعكاس وتحديداً
هو انعكاس حول الخط الموازي لـ ket A0 الذي سنسميه L1 فقط لإعطائه
اسماً لفهم لماذا هو انعكاس من المفيد رسم صورة هنا لدينا متجهانا ket
A0 و ket A1 وهما متجهان متعامدان وحدويان ويمكننا التفكير في الشاشة كأنها تتكون من جميع التركيبات
الخطية الحقيقية لهذين المتجهين فالدائرة تمثل جميع المتجهات الوحدوية التي تكون فيها معاملات
هذين المتجهين أعداداً حقيقية هذا هو الخط L1 الموازي لـ ket A0 وإذا اعتبرنا
متجهاً عشوائياً S على هذه الدائرة فتأثير تطبيق ZF هو الانعكاس حول هذا الخط كما هو موضح على
الشاشة ببساطة لأننا لا نفعل شيئاً لـ ket A0 ونضع إشارة سالب أمام ket
A1 في الحالة الخاصة التي يكون فيها S هو ket A0 مثلاً لا يحدث شيء عند إجراء هذا الانعكاس وعندما يكون S هو
ket A1 ينقلنا الانعكاس إلى سالب ket A1 وهذا يتوافق مع فعل ZF إذن ZF هو
انعكاس يمكن تصوره كما لدينا هنا الجزء الثاني من G وهو Zor
محصور بين طبقتين من gates Hadamard يمكن التعبير عنه كـ 2 ضرب ket U bra U ناقص مصفوفة الوحدة كما
رأينا بالفعل ومرة أخرى هذا انعكاس هذه المرة حول الخط L2 الموازي لـ ket U بدلاً من ket
A0 يمكننا تصور هذه العملية بطريقة مشابهة لـ ZF هذا هو المتجه ket U
افتراضياً إذن هذا هو الخط L2 الموازي لـ ket U ومرة أخرى فعلها على متجه عشوائي S هو انعكاسه
حول الخط وهو L2 في هذه الحالة
وأخيراً كما ذكرت سابقاً عندما نركّب انعكاسين نحصل على دوران وتحديداً هو
دوران بضعف الزاوية بين خطي الانعكاس فلنرسم صورة مشابهة
لما كان لدينا من قبل هذان هما خطا الانعكاس بينهما زاوية ثيتا
وإذا أخذنا متجهاً عشوائياً S وعكسناه حول الخط الأول L1 و
ثم عكسناه حول الخط الثاني L2 فالتأثير الصافي سيكون تدوير المتجه S بزاوية ضعف ثيتا
وهذا شيء صحيح بشكل عام ويمكنكم تجربته على أمثلة إضافية خاصة بكم لتروا أن هذه هي الطريقة فعلاً
على أي حال آمل أن يساعدكم هذا في الحصول على بعض الحدس حول لماذا تأثير عملية Grover هو تدوير
المتجهات بعد ذلك سننتقل إلى مسألة اختيار عدد التكرارات T في خوارزمية Grover
لنبدأ بالتفكير في كيفية ارتباط التحليل الذي رأيناه حتى الآن والذي يكشف ما تفعله عملية Grover
عندما نطبقها بشكل متكرر على التراكب المنتظم بالمهمة التي نأمل حلها وهي إيجاد حل لمسألة البحث
أو بعبارة أخرى أي سلسلة موجودة في المجموعة A1 باختصار سنحدد
هدفاً ثم نحسب كم مرة يجب تطبيق عملية Grover للاقتراب من ذلك
الهدف أولاً لنتخيل أن لدينا أي حالة هي تركيب خطي لمتجهينا ket A0 و ket
A1 إذا أجرينا قياساً في الأساس القياسي على هذه الحالة سنحصل على نتيجة في المجموعة A1 وهي
مجموعة الحلول لمسألة البحث باحتمال يساوي مربع القيمة المطلقة لأي معامل لدينا لـ ket A1 وللـ
المتجه الموضح على الشاشة ذلك المعامل هو بيتا هذا بديهي إذا قسنا الحالة ket A0
سنحصل على لاحل عشوائي وإذا قسنا ket A1 سنحصل على حل عشوائي فإذا قسنا هذه الحالة
هنا سنحصل على لاحل عشوائي باحتمال مربع القيمة المطلقة لألفا وحل عشوائي
باحتمال مربع القيمة المطلقة لبيتا لكن يمكننا أيضاً أخذ لحظة لحسابها هذه هي الحالة مكتوبة
بحيث نرى ما هي مدخلات هذا المتجه لحالات الأساس القياسي فإذا قسنا هذه هي
الاحتمالات للحصول على كل نتيجة ممكنة وللحصول على احتمال الحصول على حل نجمع
الاحتمالات لجميع الحلول الممكنة مما يعطينا مربع القيمة المطلقة لبيتا كما
هو متوقع الآن لقد حللنا بالفعل ما يحدث عندما نشغّل خوارزمية Grover لـ T تكرار نحصل على الحالة الموضحة
هنا على الشاشة فلأن معامل ket A1 هو جيب
(2T+1) ضرب ثيتا حيث مرة أخرى هذه هي الزاوية المهمة جداً ثيتا
سنرى حلاً باحتمال تربيع جيب (2T+1) ضرب
ثيتا نريد جعل هذا الاحتمال كبيراً ومثالياً أقرب ما يمكن إلى واحد فبينما ندوّر متجه
الحالة بتكرار G سنفكر في ket A1 كحالة هدف وسنحاول
اختيار T بحيث نقترب من هذه الحالة وبينما نفعل ذلك من الجيد أن نتذكر أننا نريد أيضاً
تقليل T لأن هذا هو عدد الاستعلامات التي نحتاج لإجرائها فإذا أردنا جعل هذا
الاحتمال قريباً من واحد وتقليل T فمن المنطقي محاولة جعل زاوية متجه حالتنا قريبة من π/2 لأن
هذه هي أصغر زاوية تجعل مربع الجيب كبيراً فهي أساساً فرصتنا الأولى لجعل الاحتمال كبيراً بينما
ندوّر متجه الحالة الآن لا يمكننا بالضرورة الوصول إلى هذه الزاوية π/2 بالضبط لأن T يجب أن يكون
عدداً صحيحاً لكن إذا فكرنا فيه تقريبياً وحللنا من أجل T كأنه متباينة نرى أن مثالياً
اختيار T ليكون π/(4 ضرب ثيتا) ناقص نصف هو ما يكون
منطقياً لكن بالطبع T يجب أن يكون عدداً صحيحاً غير سالب لذا ما سنفعله هو
أخذ أقرب عدد صحيح لما نتخيله كقيمة مثالية وهو الجزء الصحيح من π مقسوماً على 4 ضرب
ثيتا أخذ الجزء الصحيح بالمناسبة يعني ببساطة أننا نتخلص من أي جزء كسري أي بعبارة أخرى هو أكبر
عدد صحيح أصغر من أو يساوي ما نأخذ جزءه الصحيح وفقاً لهذا التعبير إذا
كانت القيمة المثالية في منتصف عددين صحيحين سنقرّب لأعلى لكن هذا لن يهم فعلاً على الإطلاق بالنسبة لـ
هذا الدرس فمن الآن فصاعداً سنركز على هذا الاختيار المحدد لـ
T لكن هناك اعتبار مهم آخر يجب أن نأخذه وهو أن تحديد T هذا يعتمد
على عدد الحلول الموجودة لأن الزاوية ثيتا تعتمد على عدد
الحلول من الآن فصاعداً سأستخدم الحرف S للإشارة إلى عدد الحلول أو بعبارة أخرى حجم
المجموعة A1 فقط من أجل الراحة على أي حال النقطة هي أن
تعبيرنا لـ T القيمة التي نفترض أنها يجب أن تكون جيدة تعتمد على ثيتا وثيتا تعتمد على S وهو
حجم المجموعة A1 هذا ليس مشكلة إذا كنا نعرف مسبقاً عدد الحلول لكن
إذا لم نكن نعرف مسبقاً عدد الحلول فلا نعرف ما هي ثيتا لذا لا يمكننا اختيار T هكذا
وسيتعين علينا فعل شيء مختلف سأعود إلى الحالة التي لا نعرف فيها S بعد قليل لكن
لنبدأ بالتركيز على الحالة التي نعرف فيها عدد الحلول بدءاً من البحث الفريد
حيث هناك حل وحيد فريد مضمون نبحث
عنه ذكرت مسألة البحث الفريد كمثال على مسألة استعلام في الدرس
الخامس المدخل هو دالة f من n بت إلى بت واحد هناك سلسلة n بت فريدة
تجعل F تُقيَّم إلى واحد والهدف هو إخراج تلك السلسلة إذن
هذا مكافئ لمسألة البحث غير المنظم التي تحدثنا عنها لكن مع وعد بأن هناك حلاً واحداً بالضبط وفي الواقع هذه
هي النسخة الوحيدة من مسألة البحث التي درسها Lov Grover في ورقته الأصلية عام 1996 التي قدمت خوارزمية Grover
للبحث الفريد لدينا S يساوي 1 وبالتالي هذه الزاوية المهمة ثيتا تساوي عكس جيب
الجذر التربيعي لـ 1/N عندما يكون N كبيراً هذه القيمة تقريباً الجذر التربيعي لـ 1/N و
ذلك لأنه كلما صغرت الزوايا تبدأ دالة الجيب في الشبه أكثر فأكثر بدالة الهوية
إذا عوّضنا ذلك التقريب في اختيارنا لـ T نرى أن T تقريباً يساوي الجزء الصحيح من
π/4 ضرب الجذر التربيعي لـ N هذا جيد لأننا في طريقنا لاستخدام O كبير من الجذر التربيعي لـ N
استعلاماً رغم أننا في هذه المرحلة لم ننظر بعد في مدى جودة أداء الخوارزمية
بالضبط لننظر إلى مثال حيث N الكبير يساوي 128 وهو 2 أس 7 إذن
دالتنا f هي من سبعة بتات إلى بت واحد ونفترض أن هناك حلاً فريداً لكن لمعرفة مدى
جودة عمل الخوارزمية نحتاج فعلاً فقط لأن نهتم بالزاوية ثيتا التي يمكننا حسابها هي
تقريباً 0.0885 راديان وهو أكثر قليلاً من 5 درجات وإذا عوّضنا تلك القيمة في
تعبيرنا لـ T نحصل على ثمانية فنحن نفكر فيما يحدث عندما نبحث عن حل فريد من بين 128
احتمالاً باستخدام ثمانية استعلامات يمكننا رسم صورة لتوضيح كيف تتغير الحالة مع
الوقت بينما نجري تكرارات لعملية Grover كما من قبل لدينا الحالتان ket
A0 و ket A1 وفي هذه الحالة المحددة أي البحث الفريد ket A1 هي في الواقع حالة الأساس القياسي
المقابلة للحل الفريد مهما كان بينما ket A0 هي التراكب المنتظم على جميع
السلاسل غير الحل الفريد هذا هو التراكب المنتظم على جميع السلاسل الذي يمكننا
كتابته كـ جيب تمام ثيتا ket A0 زائد جيب ثيتا ket A1 ومن المنطقي أن ket A0
و ket U قريبتان في هذه الحالة لأنه كما لاحظنا للتو ket A0 هي
تقريباً التراكب المنتظم على جميع السلاسل هناك سلسلة واحدة فقط مفقودة وهي الحل الفريد تطبيق G مرة أخرى يدوّر بـ
2 ثيتا إضافية فهذا موقعنا بعد تكرارين هذا ثلاثة 4 5 6 7 و 8
والآن نرى أننا قريبون جداً من ket A1 فإذا توقفنا وقسنا في هذه النقطة سيكون من المرجح جداً الحصول على
الحل الفريد وفي الواقع في هذه الحالة هناك فقط حوالي نصف بالمئة احتمال أن لا نحصل على الحل
الفريد من ناحية أخرى لو واصلنا تطبيق عملية Grover أكثر من الثمان مرات الموصى بها
فإن احتمال الحصول على حل سينخفض مجدداً ومع الوقت سيتذبذب بينما تدور الحالة حول
الدائرة لذا من المهم أن نوقف التكرارات في الوقت المناسب إذا أردنا النجاح باحتمال
عالٍ لنفكر في احتمال أن اختيارنا لـ T يكشف الحل الفريد بشكل أعم لقيم مختلفة من
N سنكتب p(N,1) للدلالة على احتمال نجاح خوارزمية Grover في إيجاد حل فريد
لكل قيمة ممكنة من N الواحد يعني حلاً واحداً وسنوسع هذا الترميز لأعداد أخرى من الحلول
قريباً هذا جدول لهذه الاحتمالات لقوى صغيرة من اثنين يبدأ بـ N يساوي 2 و
الاحتمال هو 1/2 وهو ليس جيداً جداً لكن عند N يساوي 4 الاحتمال هو واحد بالضبط فهي تعمل
بشكل مثالي في هذه الحالة وهو تمرين رائع بالمناسبة أن تمروا صراحة على كيفية عمل هاتين الحالتين
خاصة حالة N يساوي أربعة في تلك الحالة نبحث عن حل واحد من أصل أربعة احتمالات
نحتاج استعلاماً واحداً فقط وتعمل بشكل مثالي كلما كبر N نرى بعض التقلبات الاحتمالات ترتفع
وتنخفض قليلاً لكنها تبدو وكأنها تقترب من واحد وبالفعل هذا صحيح يمكن إثباته
تحليلياً أن الاحتمال دائماً على الأقل 1 - 1/N وهذا جيد
الخوارزمية ليست مثالية لسنا مضمونين الحصول على حل لكنه مرجح جداً خاصة لقيم
N الكبيرة بالإضافة إلى الحالة الشاذة المثيرة جداً التي تحدث عندما N يساوي 4
يجب أن أشير أيضاً إلى أنه يمكننا دائماً تشغيل الخوارزمية بأكملها بما في ذلك القياسات عدة مرات نختارها وإذا نجح أي تشغيل
سنحصل على حل فإذا لم تكن هذه الاحتمالات كافية يمكننا تعزيزها بسهولة بتشغيل
الخوارزمية مرة أخرى في الواقع حتى لو كانت هذه الاحتمالات كلها تساوي 1/2 مثلاً فسيكون لدينا
خوارزمية بحث مفيدة الآن لنفكر فيما يحدث عندما تكون هناك حلول
متعددة لنبدأ بمثال مشابه لما قبل مرة أخرى N يساوي 128 لكن هذه المرة
عدد الحلول S هو أربعة بدلاً من واحد مرة أخرى يمكننا حساب ثيتا و T و
نحصل على أن ثيتا حوالي 0.1777 أو أكثر قليلاً من 10 درجات و T يساوي
أربعة هذه المرة فالزاوية تقريباً ضعف القيمة من المثال السابق و T نصف ما كان
عليه يمكننا رسم صورة كما من قبل هذا مكان
البداية هذا تكرار واحد اثنان ثلاثة وأربعة هذه المرة نحن قريبون جداً من ket
A1 واحتمال الحصول على حل هذه المرة يتبين أنه أكبر من
99.9% لكن لو لم نكن نعرف أفضل واعتقدنا أن هناك حلاً واحداً فقط لكنا اخترنا T ليساوي 8 كما
من قبل لكنا دُرنا تقريباً بالكامل لنصل إلى سالب ket A0 وهذا سيؤدي إلى احتمال نجاح صغير جداً
فهذا مثال إضافي يُظهر أن هناك اختيارات جيدة لـ T واختيارات سيئة لـ T وهنا نرى
أن اختياراً جيداً لـ S يساوي 1 يتبين أنه اختيار سيء جداً لـ S يساوي 4 لكن بافتراض أننا نعرف S
مسبقاً ونختار T وفقاً لتحديدنا فيتبين أن خوارزمية Grover ستجد حلاً
باحتمال على الأقل 1 - S/N وغالباً سيكون أكبر بكثير من ذلك وهو أيضاً على الأقل S/N لكن
هذا في الواقع أقل إثارة للاهتمام الأكثر إثارة هو أنه كلما صغر الكسر S/N اقترب الحد الأدنى
لاحتمال النجاح أكثر فأكثر من واحد كما ذكرت بالفعل عدة
مرات الرقم T يمثل ليس فقط عدد تكرارات عملية Grover التي نجريها بل أيضاً عدد
الاستعلامات التي نجريها فكيف يعتمد هذا الرقم على S و
N أولاً لنبدأ بحقيقة أن عكس جيب X دائماً أكبر من أو يساوي X بشرط أن X بين 0 و 1
هذا سهل الإثبات إذا كنت تعرف متسلسلة تايلور لدالة عكس الجيب لكن هناك طرق أخرى للتفكير فيه ونحن فقط
سنأخذه كمُسلَّمة لأنه صحيح هذا يعني أن ثيتا على الأقل تساوي الجذر التربيعي لـ S/
N وبالتالي T على الأكثر يساوي π/4 ضرب الجذر التربيعي لـ N/
S وهذا في الواقع أفضل حتى من O كبير لجذر N فكلما كبر S
بالمقارنة مع N قلّ عدد الاستعلامات التي نحتاج لإجرائها وبطريقة ما ليس مفاجئاً أن هذا الكسر يظهر
هكذا بما أن مقلوبه يعرّف ثيتا وفي نهاية المطاف ثيتا هي كل ما يهم في
هذا التحليل كما رأينا للتو خوارزمية Grover تعمل بشكل جيد جداً عندما نعرف
مسبقاً عدد الحلول لكن ماذا لو لم نكن نعرف عدد الحلول
هناك طريقة بسيطة جداً وهي ببساطة اختيار عدد التكرارات
عشوائياً وتحديداً اختيار T بشكل منتظم عشوائياً بين واحد والجزء الصحيح من π/4 ضرب جذر N يتبين أنها
طريقة جيدة جداً لفعل ذلك الحد الأعلى لهذا المدى هو تقريباً عدد الاستعلامات الذي نختاره للبحث الفريد وفي الواقع
هو العدد الصحيح بالضبط في معظم الحالات وذلك عندما تكون الزاوية ثيتا أصغر ما يمكن باستثناء
الحالة البديهية عندما لا توجد حلول الفكرة هنا أنه بدلاً من توجيه متجه حالتنا بعناية نحو
ket A1 كما فعلنا عندما كنا نعرف عدد الحلول نحن أساساً ندوّر بزاوية عشوائية كما لو أننا
نعطي متجه الحالة دورة عشوائية إذا كان هناك حل واحد فقط فقد تدفع دورتنا العشوائية
متجه الحالة قريباً من ket A1 لكنها قد تذهب به جزءاً من الطريق فقط وإذا كان هناك حلول كثيرة فقد
ترسل دورتنا العشوائية متجه الحالة حول الدائرة عدة مرات لذا لا نتوقع أن يكشف هذا عن
حل باحتمال قريب من واحد لكن فرصة أن يؤدي هذا إلى حل إن وُجد يتبين أنها
جيدة جداً دائماً على الأقل 40% في الواقع هذا ليس واضحاً لكنه هو
الحال وبالتأكيد ليس صادماً لأن زاوية عشوائية حقاً سيكون لديها 50% فرصة لإيجاد
حل على أي حال 40% ليست سيئة وتذكروا أنه يمكننا دائماً تعزيز احتمال إيجاد حل بـ
تكرار العملية مع اختيار T بشكل مستقل كل مرة وبفعل هذا فرص عدم
إيجاد حل عندما يكون موجوداً تنخفض أسّياً بعدد مرات التكرار فإذا أردنا 99%
فرصة لإيجاد حل يمكننا تشغيل هذه الطريقة البسيطة 10 مرات مرة أخرى مع اختيار T بشكل مستقل كل
مرة بطبيعة الحال إذا لم نجد حلاً نُخرج لا توجد حلول وإذا لم تكن هناك حلول
لن نجد واحداً وبالتالي في تلك الحالة سنُخرج دائماً الإجابة الصحيحة وهي لا توجد حلول إذا كانت هناك حلول
قد نفشل في إيجاد واحد ونعلن خطأً أنه لا توجد حلول لكن احتمال حدوث ذلك يمكن جعله صغيراً جداً
لدينا أيضاً كما ذكرت قبل لحظات أن هذا يتطلب عدداً من الاستعلامات أو تقييمات f هو O كبير لجذر
N فباستخدام خوارزمية Grover لا يزال بإمكاننا حل مسألة البحث باحتمال عالٍ بـ O كبير لجذر N
استعلاماً حتى لو لم نكن نعرف مسبقاً عدد الحلول هناك أيضاً طريقة أكثر
تطوراً يمكن أن تؤدي إلى تخفيض في عدد الاستعلامات مع زيادة عدد الحلول لن أصفها
بالتفصيل وبدلاً من ذلك سأركز فقط على الفكرة الرئيسية نبدأ بـ T الكبير يساوي
واحداً ثم نشغّل خوارزمية Grover لعدد عشوائي من التكرارات لكن بحد أعلى هو T فأول
مرة نصل للخطوة الثانية سنشغّل خوارزمية Grover بتكرار واحد لكن T سيكون
يكبر إذا وجدنا حلاً نُخرج ذلك الحل ونتوقف وإذا لم نجد حلاً نجعل T
أكبر ونحاول مرة أخرى وفي مرحلة ما قبل أن يصبح T كبيراً جداً سننهي العملية و
نعلن أنه لا توجد حلول هي نفس الفكرة الأساسية كما في الطريقة البسيطة حيث نعطي
متجه الحالة دورات عشوائية بالأساس لكن هنا نبدأ بدورات أخف أولاً حيث T
صغير تحسباً لوجود حلول كثيرة بهذه الطريقة لن نهدر استعلامات بجعل الحالة تدور حول
الدائرة مراراً بالدوران بقوة مفرطة لكن إذا لم ينجح ذلك بمعنى أننا لم نجد حلاً نحاول مرة أخرى
لكن ندور بقوة أكبر قليلاً أو بإمكانية أكبر قليلاً لجعل هذا يعمل يجب اختيار معدل
زيادة T بعناية وطريقة لجعله يعمل هي استبدال T بسقف 5/4 ضرب T
فـ T يتزايد أسّياً وبشكل حدسي يمكننا التفكير فيه كأننا ندور بقوة أكبر بنسبة 25% كل
مرة ومن المهم للتحليل أن T يتزايد أسّياً هكذا لماذا 5/4 قد تسألون حسناً هو
مجرد رقم يعمل وهناك في الواقع مدى من القيم التي تعمل لكن 2 لا يعمل مثلاً مضاعفة T
كل مرة زيادة سريعة جداً للاستفادة الكاملة من فوائد الدورات الأخف على أي حال الهدف من هذه الطريقة الأكثر
تطوراً هو أنها تعطي نفس الحد المقارب على عدد الاستعلامات التي نحتاجها كما كان لدينا من قبل
O كبير لجذر N/S لكننا لا نحتاج لمعرفة مسبقة بعدد الحلول وبالمناسبة
يمكننا إيقاف هذه العملية عندما يصل T إلى جذر N فإذا لم تكن هناك حلول سنصل لتلك النتيجة بعد O كبير
لجذر N استعلاماً وهكذا يمكننا اختيار عدد التكرارات في خوارزمية Grover لاختتام الدرس
سأقدم بعض الملاحظات المختصرة حول خوارزمية Grover أولاً ضمن نموذج الاستعلام
خوارزمية Grover مثالية مقاربياً وما يعنيه ذلك هو أنه ليس من الممكن ابتكار
خوارزمية استعلام لحل مسألة البحث أو حتى مسألة البحث الفريد تحديداً تستخدم مقاربياً
أقل من O كبير لجذر N استعلاماً في أسوأ الحالات هذا شيء يمكن إثباته بشكل صارم
وهناك في الواقع عدة براهين معروفة لهذه الحقيقة المثير للاهتمام أن هذا كان معروفاً حتى
قبل اكتشاف خوارزمية Grover خوارزمية Grover طابقت الحد الأدنى المعروف مسبقاً لعدد
الاستعلامات المطلوبة من وقت لآخر يأتي أشخاص بطرق يعتقدون أنها مقاربياً
أفضل من خوارزمية Grover لكن يكون هناك دائماً إما خطأ أو افتراض حول الدالة f و
كيفية الوصول إليها أو مشكلة أخرى تجعل الادعاء غير صحيح إذا كنت تعمل بشكل صحيح
ضمن نموذج الاستعلام فلا يمكنك التفوق على خوارزمية Grover للبحث غير المنظم ثانياً خوارزمية Grover
قابلة للتطبيق على نطاق واسع بمعنى أن تسريع الجذر التربيعي الذي تقدمه خوارزمية Grover لمسألة البحث غير المنظم يمكن
الحصول عليه في مجموعة متنوعة من السياقات المختلفة مثلاً أحياناً يمكن استخدام خوارزمية Grover فوق
خوارزمية أخرى للحصول على تحسن تربيعي يتجاوز أداء تلك الخوارزمية خوارزمية Grover أيضاً
تُستخدم بشكل شائع جداً كروتين فرعي داخل خوارزميات كمية أخرى كمثال بسيط
يمكننا استخدام خوارزمية Grover للحصول على ميزة تربيعية على الخوارزميات الكلاسيكية لمسألة الحد الأدنى التي ذكرتها في
الدرس الخامس وأخيراً التقنية المستخدمة في خوارزمية Grover حيث لدينا انعكاسان
يُركَّبان ويُكرَّران لتدوير متجه حالة كمية يمكن تعميمها بشكل
كبير جداً مثال على ذلك تقنية تُعرف بتضخيم السعة حيث عملية
تعمّم خوارزمية Grover يمكن تطبيقها على خوارزمية كمية أخرى لتعزيز احتمال نجاحها بشكل تربيعي أسرع مما
هو ممكن كلاسيكياً وتلك التقنية لها تطبيقات واسعة في الخوارزميات الكمية فقد يكون صحيحاً أن
خوارزمية Grover ليست مرجحة أن تؤدي إلى ميزة كمية عملية في أي وقت قريب إن حدث ذلك أصلاً لكن خوارزمية Grover
بلا شك خوارزمية كمية مهمة جوهرياً وقابلة للتطبيق على نطاق واسع وهي تمثل تقنية أعم لها استخدامات
عديدة وهذا كل شيء لهذا الدرس ولهذه الوحدة من السلسلة التي كانت عن الخوارزميات
الكمية ناقشنا نموذج الاستعلام وكيف يمكننا ربطه بنموذج أكثر قياسية للحوسبة إلى جانب
بعض المفاهيم الأساسية الأخرى حول كيفية قياس التكلفة الحسابية ثم غطينا تقدير الطور
والتحليل إلى عوامل ثم أخيراً خوارزمية Grover كما اقترحت بالفعل
هناك الكثير لتتعلموه عن الخوارزميات الكمية لكن في هذه السلسلة سننتقل إلى موضوع مختلف في الوحدة القادمة وبالتحديد سنلقي
نظرة على الصياغة العامة للمعلومات الكمية حيث تُمثَّل الحالات الكمية بمصفوفات من نوع
معين تُعرف بمصفوفات الكثافة كما سنرى هذه الصياغة مفيدة جداً وفي الواقع
ضرورية لفهم بعض جوانب المعلومات الكمية وهي أيضاً جميلة جداً من وجهة نظر
رياضية لذا آمل أن تنضموا إليّ في الوحدة الثالثة وإلى اللقاء حتى
ذلك الحين